[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the film's score
for harry potter one of the most famous
and widely recognized film scores
in the entire history of cinema more
specifically
we're going to be looking at arguably
the most famous track
of all of the tracks across all of the
harry potter films
hedwig's theme hedwig's theme is magical
i don't think
there's any argument to be made there
it's the perfect piece of music
to accompany the harry potter films and
it was the perfect introduction to the
series
as it served as an impressive
accompaniment that fit the story that we
were about to be told
like a glove film scores are dangerous
territory
because a poor film score can certainly
ruin what would otherwise be
a good film not that powerful on the
other side of that
a good film score can enhance an already
good film
and that's exactly what happened with
harry potter in fact the score for harry
potter went above and beyond
a successful film score blends into the
background
and strengthens the narrative but a
blowout film score
takes on a life of its own and that's
exactly what happened with the iconic
hedwig's theme as soon as we hear the
opening notes of hedwig's theme
we're taken away to a magical world as
if we've become immersed in the magic
so who's responsible for creating such a
marvelous piece of music
why none other than john williams of
course john williams
born in 1932 is perhaps the most
prolific
and widely honoured living composer of
film music
he's also received the most oscar
nominations for film scores
of anyone ever star wars jurassic park
indiana jones home alone jaws and many
many more these were all the work of
williams
today i want to discuss the primary
instrument behind hedwig's theme
the instrument that upon hearing just
those first few notes
renders us entirely captivated i wanted
to make this video because i had never
heard of this instrument
until just a few years ago and i thought
you guys might be interested to hear
about the sole instrument responsible
for the most widely recognized film
track
of all time at first i just didn't
really think about how those magical
notes were created
but a bit later i did and i came to the
conclusion that it was probably some
kind of digitized piano
that was altered substantially in
post-production
however when i researched it i came
across the
celesta it turned out that the primary
force behind such an iconic piece of
music
came from a little piano type instrument
by this name
the celesta was invented in 1886 by the
parisian harmonian builder
auguste mustel the celesta also called a
bell piano
is a struck idiophone operated by
keyboard
it looks similar to an upright piano
four or five octave
albeit with smaller keys and a much
smaller cabinet
or a large wooden music box three octave
the keys connect to hammers
that strike a graduated set of metal
usually steel
plates or bars suspended over wooden
resonators
because the celesta is such an uncommon
instrument its sound is almost
ethereal which is why it's so
captivating and why it has had
such a profound impact on cinema the
celesta is cited to sound
heavenly and heavenly sounding it is
but what made hedwig's theme sound
absolutely otherworldly
was the additional electronic
manipulation in post
apart from harry potter the celeste was
also famously used
in dance of the sugarplum fairy from
tchaikovsky's the nutcracker
anyway that's it for this video i hope
you enjoyed this different style of
video for a change
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
you're a wizard harry
you